when you have a secret that is deranging
your life
there's both an urge to purge and an
urge to avoid
and you see both of these things in
certain people which is that they're
trying to get back home to normal
you know they've been exposed to some
piece of information you know to be
blunt War used to create divisions where
somebody had seen Warren somebody hadn't
and how do they live under the same roof
now that one of them has seen something
that the other can't even imagine
you know so
if this in fact breaks you out of polite
Society
um it's entirely consistent to have
somebody with a basic Limelight avoiding
personality who's going to keep going
back to the well because at some level
they're trying to say I'm not crazy and
I you know just to be very clear about
it
part of my
desire to stick up for people out here
is that I watch the power to silence
that comes from stigma and shame in
particular stigma and shame as
entertainment
um yeah and the idea of laughing at
people like the use of the words clown
buffoon debunk
um LOL rotfl
it
most people can't stand up to this
and it really bugs me that an entire
group in the world thinks it's
completely okay to destroy an individual
who dares raise a voice
and that's
the non-science reason I'm out here in
UFO territory is is that which is I
can't stand
basically bullying
and gaslighting people who've seen
something want answers want to ask
questions
and then somehow it's like there was a
secret meeting where everybody decided
the truth and you weren't part of it and
the basic attitude towards people who
engage in this kind of gaslighting is Fu
science has your back these people don't
belong in our minions in our community
and they have to be driven out
is in a very serious position trying to
orchestrate the idea that only
um you know racists entertain the lab
leak hypothesis everybody should want to
know what the hell he was doing in the
Wuhan Institute of virology with defense
department funding
conversely
when we turn over to the UFO Community
you know the issue is I don't want
people who have seen something or who
have data
scared anymore
and it's very scared of I mean you keep
talking about this debunking community
but who exactly are you referring to I
mean I'm not a person who mocks people
so that just comes across to me as
playing I'll be blunt that comes across
to me as playing dumb
no I think that lots of people are no no
I'm a genuine question it's a genuine
question because there's not very many
UFO debunkers out there
I think it's a it's a really
disingenuous sounding question yeah I
may have I may have you wrong Mick but
are you going to agree yes
I can tell you that I find your
interaction unpleasant it's like I've
never
I've never said
I've never said anything like this is
real it's true or did you hear about the
Nimitz incident or you know with these
new cameras they can tell that like
that's not my energy my energy is oh I
was lied to
I was lied to about many things for
example psychedelics I was told that you
know acid would destroy your your body
and in your brain and turns out that
it's very well tolerated
um and even micrograms you know the the
dose needed to kill you I think is not
known because it it's so well tolerated
when I found out that I had been lied to
about psychedelics I was very angry
because I had taken on the trust the the
government knows what it's talking about
and these were dangerous substances in
the case of UFOs I've been lied to it is
very clear that a lot of very smart
people
had feel that they have had their lives
destroyed over taking this seriously as
a topic and nobody what not by me yeah
perhaps by colleagues and perhaps by the
the government why do I have the
impression that you police UFOs
uh
I wouldn't say that what do you mean
when you say that Eric what do you mean
I forget what our last interaction was
Mick but somehow I tried to say
something general and you tried to bring
it back to like Lou Elizondo and Chris
Mellon and I don't remember what I was
but well does it look it doesn't much
matter but I think what I'm trying to
get at is are you unaware that people
feel that they've been ridiculed and
have had their credibility shredded
because of something that they they
sincerely believe they came in contact
with as either data or a primary
experience well you know I all right
let's let's
kind of in a way showed that question a
little bit because I think we can
perhaps divide uh the experiences into
two groups uh one group would be the
experiences who are sensitive and will
get upset by that type of thing and you
know wouldn't like uh that and then the
other ones are the people who you know
they don't don't uh don't really care
people like David fravor they come out
he didn't have his life ruined he's
given this extensive discussion uh of uh
of his encounter and nothing happened to
him his career was just fine okay well
now we're in territory where I can map
this very well no things did happen I
don't need to know him perfect
personally I've never met him I've never
had a conversation with him but I can
tell you two things that have happened
one thing is is that people have treated
him as a Nutter
and the other thing is that people have
celebrated him as a uh as a
truth-seeking hero
both of these things happen to you out
here
and it's pretty disturbing when people
treat you as a Nutter and you're saying
something that's pretty sober like
I was minding my business when the
following thing happened to me and I'm
not responsible for it
you have the sense that he's lying no I
don't uh I do not have a sense he's
lying most people who have some kind of
experience I do not think that they are
lying but people often say that I am
saying that people lie I think you know
he's telling what he thinks what he
thought happened
I think his memory may have changed over
time and his initial perception may have
been faulty but so you have no
perception that people are paying a
personal price
for saying I was in contact with data
I've seen data or I was I had a direct
experience
all of them everyone's been prevented
from coming forward no one's laying I
got the uh the cajonas to actually Step
Up
you know I don't want to like you know
belittle people who who who have genuine
trauma uh from these encounters and
their reaction to the encounters but it
doesn't explain the complete lack of
this type of thing where people actually
coming forward
well I mean nobody came forward from
cointel Pro and that was a pretty large
operation to stay hidden I mean there's
a a Trope at the moment that the
government can't they legally required
not to come forward and then if you have
a situation in which
um the government is alleged to keep a
secret somebody now says oh I don't
believe three people can keep a secret
much less thousands as if D-Day was
never planned I mean this is just it's
sort of this willful playing dumb that I
don't understand it doesn't seem like to
be honest I understand your point you
understand your point you know there's
this kind of just chilling effect uh of
of of uh mockery yeah I don't think that
what I am doing is mockery and you know
I don't really see
um
a huge amount of evidence of some kind
of organized group of people doing it
you talk about this the debunking
community
but I don't think the debunking
community is really having this big of
an effect on people's lives
so you do see the snide remarks or the
disparagement against people who come
out either saying that they've witnessed
something firsthand or that they just
want to investigate the phenomenon for
example Avila so you do see that there's
this esteem at times from no nebulous
source
yeah it's like I talked about before
like it's something that's always been
there in UFOs it's this stigma which
hinders uh genuine investigation but
unfortunately it's something that arises
naturally from the somewhat uh
ridiculous nature of of some of the
stories that are in ufology and some of
the things like the the hoaxes and the
silly photos but yeah it's a problem
that is an impediment to Serious
research and it's you know it's it's
something that I've increasingly tried
to avoid uh when I've been talking to
people and you know I get feedback all
the time but yes I come across as being
uh you know perhaps abrasive or perhaps
uh seeming like I'm mocking and I take
you know Eric's uh perception to Heart
here that perhaps you know my my uh
discussions with people in my encounters
with people are not always uh enjoyable
and I perhaps I don't mind should not
enjoyable to improve that yeah the thing
is
I came very close to blocking your
account not it didn't make me happy
because I feel like you have a lot to
contribute and I really do value
getting rid of
um the idea that nothing can explain
these videos because I think that's
completely Preposterous you know we're
in a world in which the Matrix and Star
Wars have shown us things far more
interesting than these videos and the
idea that you can't create these videos
any other way is ridiculous now that
said I just don't
it's more like the role you're playing
is is like a border collie keeping these
people away from Chemtrails and Flat
Earth
it's like if the conserved quantity
imagine for example you gave it grew up
in a religious family I know nothing
about your family I'm not making this as
a client I grew up Catholic okay
it's entirely possible that in a in a
family in which mythology is rammed down
your throat you better believe and only
bad people don't believe that you pick
up an energy which is I hate forced
belief and I hate it when stories become
so big that people crawl inside of a
story and lose their family and lose
their mind I've met people who've been
in a cult-like environment yeah their
key thing is we've got to make sure that
we don't let any cult-like beliefs in
the door
and then I've grown up you know myself
as an atheist and an atheistic family
for like five generations and my feeling
is in part that that Relentless focus on
let's not believe anything that can't be
demonstrated in a lab has its own set of
problems
um it's very hard to do The Cutting Edge
research if you can never believe in
your own imagination enough
to let it run wild for a while you know
and my personal belief is that we should
all have a creative side and a debunking
side living inside of our brains where
we're debunking our creative
impulse
yeah because it's a part tied to like
ego you know and
the issue that I'm having though is is
that the skeptic energy and the
scientific energy
things have tilted far enough with the
with what we now believe to be true
that it's really important to me that we
stop scaring pilots who may
like if you if your explanation is
somebody's under a lot of stress
or that somebody needs a psychological
workup because they might be having a
psychotic break or that somebody may be
hallucinating a lot of the explanations
that may not involve UAP
um
are of a personal sort of psychological
characterological nature and to somebody
who might have as their employment plan
that they're going to fly commercial
aircraft after they're stint in the Navy
they're not going to want to come
forward
if your explanation is affection
effectively that these were phosphines
or the person may have you know had a
a flashback from uh an acid trip from a
few years ago
I want people to feel comfortable saying
what they've seen without this extra
light
well we now kind of have that in some uh
some Arenas like specifically the Navy
training ranges where we've got a couple
of these videos from they now have
specific guidelines in place for
reporting uh you know this type of
encounter and they're actually
encouraged to do it now we also have
with the FAA a strong encouragement uh
with Pilots to report drone sightings
and they don't need to be necessarily
identified as a specific type of drone
and so we're actually getting a bunch of
UFO reports because of this this
emphasis on on looking at drones you
know things that essentially I saw a
it's a happy accident in terms of drones
becoming a threat that is a happy
accident yeah but the Navy thing was a
specific response to the UFO uh thing it
was it was something that they
recognized that there was this stigma
and they tried to they tried to remove
the stigma and that's that's a laudable
thing and I think I was you know it's
showing results let me try to put it
a different sheen on it so a last
attempt to make the point
I am
very much more careful
I want to figure out how to phrases I am
much more careful when I hear somebody
talking about Chemtrails for example if
they come from the Black American
community
then if they don't
and I'm much more
understanding if somebody comes from a
radical Progressive family
that went through the McCarthy era and
they don't trust the government
so in other words when particular groups
of people are repeatedly lied to
and manipulated and have a different
history than the rest of the country
I tend to take their
fears much more seriously if you went
through the Tuskegee medical experiment
it's not that crazy to worry about
what's in a vaccine
if you didn't go through the Tuskegee
medical experiment if your community
wasn't subjected to that you may have a
very different sense that
you know something's going on or if
you're aware that we've experimented
with biological agents involuntarily
against people in subway stations
there's all sorts of weird stuff that
we've gotten up to
I forget there was a ship that maybe was
supposed to disperse something so it
could be recorded
the history of secret government
behavior is not a great history whether
it's Operation Ajax or Operation Condor
who knows what
and the pressure not to question these
things because the conspiracy theory
really bothers me because we have a
group that is simultaneously engaging in
conspiracies and not clearing up things
that they could clear up which does feel
that personal destruction is a good way
to keep secrets
and I guess what I'm asking you is can
you be a bit more charitable to people
who've been lied to okay uh that's you
know a perfectly reasonable request I
think and uh yes yes I think I can and
you know I'd like to invite other people
who are watching this to give me
feedback on you know whether they like
you know not necessarily just agree
disagree but like in what way
could I do better in what way could the
debunking community do better and what
specifically should we do because I I
interview people uh who have had
experiences you know a number of uh
people like you know say Kevin day one
of the guys off the Nimitz and Gary
vorhis another guy from the Nimitz
encounters different ship uh but
I'm nice of them I'm not mocking them
what a lot of what I'm doing in my just
day-to-day stuff isn't like questioning
people's eyewitness accounts I very
rarely actually take cases uh where it's
just an eyewitness account
simply because there's not a lot you can
do with it and it often it's it gets
very contentious because people are very
emotional about their things so a lot of
what I do is just simply the nuts and
bolts type thing of looking at uh
individual videos and uh photos and
things like that so you know if I could
do something that was better in terms of
of Outreach to people who have had
experiences
um yes but I think it's really more
about kind of in a way avoiding
that type of Confrontation because
there's not a lot you can do
with someone who just has an eyewitness
experience someone who tells you I saw
this this black triangle you know I
talked to quite a few of them you know
kind of online on Twitter and there's
only so far you can go
you could perhaps like perhaps do a
hypothesis to what it might be you can
listen to their their explanations and
you can ask them questions about you
know what angular size do you think it
would be like how many hand widths would
it be and you know what time it was and
where were you but at some point you
know you enter the low information Zone
and there's not much further you can go
and I I generally just say well I mean I
can't really help you I don't mock them
I don't like make fun of them and in
general I don't I don't mock people so
yeah I'm sure there are things I can do
to improve
but I I don't really accept your kind of
characterization of me of being part of
this very dangerous uh Community uh you
know I think you you described it as an
Abomination that we need to get rid of
the debunking community in in your your
last last thing yeah I mean I think that
the point is that these people are not
necessarily Bunko artists but that's
nothing but you're not I think what
you're not figuring out is when you come
at something from the point of view of
debunking it
right what you're really doing that's
what I was saying from the very start is
that you know with UFOs what I do is
come at it from the perspective of
investigating it to try to figure out
what that thing is if someone comes to
me with a story of what they they saw
that you don't use the word I'm an
investigator
I'm moving away from it for oh you're
moving away I said at the start yeah
that uh um yeah what's his name the
either the pilot Ryan Graves you know he
told me he didn't want to talk to me
because I had debunk you know I always
try to I've been trying to reframe
debunking as a positive thing because it
is about investigating things to see
whether they are true or false it's not
about working towards a certain result
well maybe think about it from the
follow
I understand that one of the things
that's very interesting to some of us
who do commentary uh on social issues is
that people who are employed by Legacy
Media outfits react to anybody who makes
a living as an individual not attached
to a Legacy Media outfit they refer to
these people as grifters in order to
give the idea that you can trust Harpers
in the Atlantic but if somebody is
telling you something on the Internet
then it's probably nonsense
I think that what you have to understand
is is that bunk and bunco and the idea
of fooling people
I appreciate that you're moving away
from it but maybe a repudiation of the
energy around that
is really necessary because it's one
thing to say yeah I'm trying to use that
less
a lot of the fun
that comes from skepticism is mixing in
this dunking and dragging and whether or
not one is actually doing the dunking
and just let me let me get to the end of
this whether one is actually doing the
dunking and dragging or whether one is
painting a bullseye on a target for
someone else to execute
I think is really kind of the issue
and my feeling
go on all right I'm not yeah I don't I'm
not the snoc in the debunking and the
dragging like and you're saying I'm
painting a Target on uh things by by
actually investigating it and figuring
out what it is and they know that people
can make fun of it
that's you know is that on me that I
investigate something and it turns out
not to be true and that for other people
I don't uh perhaps mock whoever came up
with a thing originally I don't think
that
all one has to do is to say look I
really don't want these people ridiculed
not like add a disclaimer at the end of
all my investigations and so don't make
fun of people because no no look they're
going to do it they're our Bunko artists
right there are people who are trying to
deceive other people let's say for
profit okay sure I think that it is
reasonable to return fire against such
people at a proportionate level right a
fair game I think that well to a point
right I mean you know
what if someone is a shelter and then
they are basically selling nonsense for
money then yes I think they deserve to
be somebody's a Charlotte the community
has the right to drive their costs in a
particular way up to a point right but
you know what we're seeing here in my
estimation is that there are a lot of
people who confide in me and say that
they are frightened or they say I really
appreciate you entering into this space
because I couldn't even talk to my own
family
and there's just sort of no emotional
affect
that I see in you when I'm like I
believe that you and I both know this to
be true uh that could be false because
I'm making the assumption that we both
know this
but I have now heard from so many people
that they're frightened by what they
experienced or what they saw
that for you to say well like who's it
who's frightened who's experienced
nothing bad happened to David fair I
don't need to know David fravor to know
that lots of good and lots of bad
pardon me I said that there must be some
people who are not frightened by what
they saw other people
yeah there's people who do are deeply
affected by it but there's people who
just simply will see it as a scientific
observation and they'll be able to
report it we don't see very many people
almost nobody I know who's not
independently wealthy can afford to say
oh that was interesting
would you want a surgeon operating on
your child if
uh the the surgeon had had lots of
discussions with aliens sure I mean yeah
I would
it's a perfectly normal thing for
someone to see something in the sky and
think it's this weird thing this happens
all the time if somebody told me that
they were abducted by aliens and they
wanted to operate on my kid I'll be
honest that would tutor my prior to say
I don't want to take that risk that this
person might be a line
yeah
yeah but like simply saying uh craft in
the sky that is that's a different thing
entirely I think that's a very
understandable thing to happen to people
and there will be inevitably some people
who have some kind of
misperception or Illusion that uh you
know it isn't doesn't deserve mockery
certainly not it's a perfectly
understandable thing and you know I tell
people this when I talk to them that
yeah I can see how this maybe we've
taken this even even that is a very
sensitive thing or even that uh they
they see that as being
um dismissive uh so it's it's difficult
to like I say I tried to stay away from
that type of thing to your point I think
it's completely reasonable to say we may
have to dismiss some things that are
very deeply personally held as beliefs
and people may get very injured but the
fact is we can't afford to be taking
this as some super serious threat let's
say to our nuclear Arsenal because uh
Mrs O'Connell uh thought she saw a
cigar-shaped object hovering in her
backyard for half a second
yeah I think there's there's real
serious issues in ufology there are
unidentified flying things uh that
people have seen and we should
investigate what they are all the
reasons why people are seeing these
things and I I agree like let's let's
get away from the stigma of it and then
we'll get closer to some resolution one
way or another I join with you on that
and uh I think that's very positive
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy